My name is from the AfD
mirell and i am running for the
European Parliament for the left.
i was born in,
am with 5 years as a daughter
of a political refugee family to Germany
come and my family is,
Alevi and besides,
my father is 1st a communist.
that's why it was like this,
that My father was someone,
who experienced torture in the military coup in Turkey
and my family knows all that too,
what that means,
when there is no democracy,
when there's no freedom,
when there's no justice.
in this respect I have heard from this
Family soaked up with the breast milk,
that I have to fight back somehow,
when there is something unjust.
i have the right-wing and ,
who sit in the European Parliament and people like me,
so people with an escape experience
we all become open criminally,
openly and offensively stood up to,
love, enjoyed,
enjoyed and I am proud to be with you
together in this openly anti- party
continue also against the
strengthening the right-wing struggle.
I have organized demonstration against wars,
I have organized protests against,
I have anti-racism
Demonstration also organized,
am a founding member of the left,
because the left was the party,
that for social justice
and fought for peace.
for 4 years i am already in the europapalament
for the left
and there I fight for social justice.
i argued for it,
that,
for example, a
European minimum wage directive finally adopted
has been and I am active in the European Parliament
against the EU currently converting.
becomes in a military union,
because that does not make the EU or the world safer.
I actually think of people like Klara Z.
King,
who fought for women's equality.
to people like Rosa Luxemburg and khalibknecht,
the against the 1..
World War have risen
and even left their lives for it,
that more and more people do not die.
to people who just know,
where they come from and for whom they make politics.
to people who have 1 class consciousness.
in times of peace
it is easy to be against war,
but to stand up for peace in times of war,
that requires courage.
and thank you,
love enjoyed,
that I can do this together with you.